And now, great moments in unintended
consequences.
Part one: See Shores.
The year: 2003.
The problem: There's a photo of
Barbra Streisand's house on the
Internet.
The solution: sue the photographer
for $50 million
and demand the photo be removed.
Sounds like a great idea, with
the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
It turns out when you try and hide
something, people get interested.
The aerial image, part of a larger
project to document coastal erosion,
had only been downloaded six times
before Streisand got upset.
But in the month following the
lawsuit, over 400,000
people clicked on the image of
Streisand's house.
Babs lost her case, was forced to
pay 177,000 in
legal fees and the Streisand
effect is now shorthand for bringing
unwanted attention to the very thing
being suppressed.
Maybe next time, don't mention
it. Part two: Open
Sesame.
The year: 2022.
The problem: Over
a million Americans are allergic
to sesame seeds.
The solution: Add them to
the FDA's major allergens list,
which requires food manufacturers
and restaurants to disclose if
products either contain or might
have come in contact with the seeds.
Sounds like a great idea, with
the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
Turns out sesame seeds are small
and a bit hard to keep track of,
making it frustrating and expensive
to guarantee seeds will not cross
contaminate other foods.
Under the stringent FDA rules, it's
not good enough to simply state that
a food may contain or is produced
in a facility that uses sesame.
So rather than go through the cost
and hassle of assuring there are
none in their product, companies
simply added small amounts and
included it to the list of
ingredients.
Presto.
Problem solved.
Unless, you know, you're allergic.
Part three: Oddball.
The year: 1994.
The problem: Ties in soccer
on boring.
The solution: Organizers
of the Caribbean Cup made game
winning overtime goals count
double, pushing teams to
play aggressively in extra time.
Sounds like a great idea, with
the best of intentions.
What could possibly go wrong?
It turns out...math.
In the last group game of the
tournament, Barbados needed to beat
Grenada by two goals to reach
the final.
Otherwise, Grenada would advance.
With only minutes left in the match,
Barbados found themselves up by
only a single goal.
Realizing their predicament,
Barbados scored on themselves.
So long as they could keep the game
tied during regular play, Barbados
could win by two with a single
score in overtime.
What followed was one of the most
bizarre 5 minutes in the history
of the game, with Barbados defending
both goals, while Grenada tried
to score in either end of the
field.
Grenada failed, Barbados scored
in overtime and the rule was
dropped. And then it rolled around
on the pitch for a while, grabbing
its knees, screaming for a penalty.
Oh, I'm so hurt.
Go....re-evaluate
your priors.
Great moments and unintended
consequences.
Good intentions, bad results.
Do you have an idea for a future
episode? Put it in the comments.
I'd like to read.